I had no idea that humans were also gurus. You
can exterminate them too. Is there a way to do that? It's a
rule that has become a dead giveaway. It's a
rule of fluid death, and it's never applied to humans. It
's like Thor's father was genuinely kind.  Don't
underestimate humans.
If you're a human trying to protect a dragon,
this
[Music] You're
slow. [
Music]
Why are you here?
Kobayashi-san, you're here. All you have to do is
call the landscaping. If
Earth
's line is good, you'll
destroy it.  Give me only the flesh and give me back my soul. I
wish for my life.
[Applause] I
killed you, but only my memories. I skipped over and
returned to my original world. I punished her a bit,
but yeah, that's
good. Now that Iruru is
relieved, I'll
wait.  Please, the
dragon's saliva has an effect on you. You
just want to lick it. Look,
Mr. Kobayashi,
lick it.